hi I'm animal Seth welcome to
neuroscience support my beer and I just
watched that episode of black Mouth
she's fantastic isn't it where they have
a device that can harvest your memories
kind of like in Meet the Robinsons
and it seems hella advanced but we can
we now implant fake ones
the future is now WTF can we implant new
memories this is possible I think in
some limited way we can implant new
memories our memories are just very
unreliable people can reliably miss
remember what happened if they're told
applause a bull story but we can also do
it more directly hypnosis is a powerful
technique it's not just some stage
trickery hypnosis is real and through
hypnosis you can induce false memories
watching ton of 90s music video today
and I am wondering where in my brain
I've stored all of these really
non-essential lyrics and if I can clear
that space with something useful now I
don't know what's non-essential about
90s music videos that's central part of
my own personality for sure so I don't
want to devote that space to anything
else at all but it's a really good
question how do we store we seem to be
able to remember an enormous amount of
information the adult human brain has
about 90 billion neurons it has about a
thousand times more connections which
means that if you counted one connection
every second it would take you about
three million years to count them all
there's a lot of connections in the
brain and if you think that a memory is
just a particular pattern of connections
distributed among a large number of
neurons the number of memories that you
could potentially store in a brain is
infinite bohemian my ass is it possible
to punch yourself in the brain so that
you just forget certain memories and
stuff like that I wish it was actually
forgetting is very adaptive it's very
useful it would be terrible to remember
everything in fact some people with
really really good memories have a lot
of problems in their lives because they
simply can't forget so is there a way to
just get rid of particular memories and
we're not quite there yet but there's
some interesting work
in just with nice at the moment that
shows that it is possible to eliminate
certain memories from nice weather that
will also apply to humans or not there's
a long way down the road but don't punch
yourself in the brain that's not gonna
do it it says old people thinking that
Millennials use social media because you
get a hit of dopamine when you get a
text do you know how Neuroscience works
dopamine this can occur in the brain
that's often associated with the
rewarding stimuli it means many things
can be rewarding it's not just a bit of
chocolate so does a tweet or a Facebook
update does that really release dopamine
in the brain it's a pretty good guess if
we find something like that rewarding
that will involve the release of
dopamine Stephan Konrath asks is it
possible to read our brain it's becoming
possible in the sense that we can record
activity from the brain now using
variety of different methods we're not
in some weird science fiction scenario
where I can point something like a hair
dryer at your head and know exactly what
you're thinking but in a more
constrained situation where the kinds of
things that you might be perceiving is
restricted then yeah we're beginning to
make progress and another way this is
really helpful is we can begin to read
from the brain Newton intentions and
this can be extremely helpful for people
with paralysis because we can start to
build what are called brain computer
interfaces and use signals directly from
the brain to control arms of control
robotic limbs and this is a great
example of why brain reading is still
quite limited on the left there's a duck
and on the right there's a
reconstruction and it doesn't look that
much like a duck yet actually and this
guy nuki canna Tommy he's actually he's
one of the world's leaders in this area
actually said kind of tiny actually he's
done some brilliant work on decoding
people's dreams because if you can
decode the brain while people are awake
you can also apply the same algorithm as
well people are dreaming and begin to
generate all these weird patterns of
what the perceptions are that the brain
might be generating why are you dreaming
KT ATK asks is there a part of the brain
that sense is a bad decision and tells
you not
do it because I don't think I have that
this is a great question it gets that
one of the central issues in
neuroscience which is freewill and there
are different parts of the brain that
are involved in the execution of
voluntary actions and in the inhibition
of voluntary actions there was a very
famous case a guy called Phineas Gage in
the 19th century was working on the
railroads and a huge piece of metal went
straight through his frontal lobes the
first miracle was that he survived after
he recovered he seemed to be fine but it
rapidly became clear that he lost all
his ability to monitor and control and
withhold his actions and he behaved
started behaving very inappropriately
what happened to him was the loss of the
part of the brain that helped exactly
this question that sense is a bad
decision and tells you not to do it
we've all been told to take a deep
breath when stressed so what is the
neuroscience behind why this quick tip
helps so much well there's a simple
answer to this which is that the brain
needs a lot of oxygen to function
properly so if you're at start of oxygen
taking deep breaths help but there's
also a more complicated story which
we're only as neuroscience is beginning
to unravel we've known for a very long
time now that decision-making doing the
right thing at the right time is very
strongly shaped by the state of our body
at a particular moment and we call it
emotion in another way so we won't make
the right decisions unless we have the
correct kind of an appropriate emotional
response as well but sometimes our
emotional response can be too
overpowering and then we'll make wrong
decisions so taking a deep breath might
just readjust this balance between what
we're thinking what emotions we're
feeling in the state our body is in so
that our brain activity in our body can
become more in alignment its
face-blindness a real thing or just an
attention-seeking thing it's a real
thing there's a condition called
prosopagnosia which is the inability to
distinguish between faces what you find
is people with prosopagnosia they're
still able to identify people but they
do it in different ways they're very
good at picking up other keys like how
somebody walks or what clothes they're
wearing or what voice sounds like but
they just cannot recognize faces when
you dream you dream of things that
you've seen and thought about and all
that so my question is do blind people
dream and if so how good question
yes blind people dream everybody dreams
fact it's not only humans that dreams
pretty much every animal with a brain at
least with this kind of cortex dreams
blind people if they've been blind from
birth maybe they won't have visual
content in their dreams but they'll
certainly have dreams very rich in other
perceptual content and nobody really
quite knows what dreams are for what
idea is that when we perceive the world
around us we have to use these very very
complex models inside our head about
what's out there in the world so we can
interpret all the sensory data that's
coming in and when we dream we're
basically sharpening and improving those
models so that they work better the next
day a rancher asks can my amygdala light
stop I wish it could the amygdala is a
walnut sized piece of the brain very
deep inside the base of the brain here
the amygdala is very heavily involved in
fear and anxiety things like that
without properly functional and nigde we
wouldn't be sufficiently scared of
things that should be scary so when we
were evolving in the African savanna as
early humans we're doing probably the
most important thing is to be scared of
the right things at the right time and
you need an amygdala to do that do you
think transcranial magnetic stimulation
treatment could alleviate PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder panic
anxiety or alt signers now transcranial
magnetic stimulation TNS is a relatively
new method and what it does is it just
injects short but very strong pulses of
electromagnetic energy into the brain
it's not very precise you can activate
one part of the brain for instance I
could activate the parietal cortex here
or the frontal cortex there so it's
pretty nonspecific and the long-term
effects are not very well known it may
be a technique which alongside many
others will help us refine new
approaches to these conditions but by
itself it doesn't provide any quick and
easy answers how does memory work is it
will it be possible to surgically
manipulate specific memories how does
memory work this is a huge question one
thing is there's more than one kind of
memory different parts of the brain are
involved in these different ways of
remember
things to say that we understand any
piece of that puzzle works would be
would be an overstatement but let's just
take one let's take autobiographical
memory how do we have none of things
that happen to us specifically now this
depends on a very specific part of the
brain called the hippocampus hippocampus
there's very deep inside the brains part
of what's called a medial temporal lobe
the hippocampus seems to take in
perceptual information as we walk around
as we move around the world and then it
consolidates these memories back out
into the rest of the brain into their
cortex so it's involved in the laying
down of new memories and memories aren't
stored in the hippocampus but we need
the hippocampus in order to lay down new
memories and in order to recover old
memories if you have damage to the
hippocampus you will not be able to lay
down any new memories you might still be
able to learn a new skill but you will
not remember what happened to you while
you were learning that skill vu asks how
does ethanol work this is a fantastic
question in fact it's a question I wish
most neuroscientists would ask
themselves again because many of us
assume we know how it works and we still
don't really fully understand what it
does now if on the rise functional
magnetic resonance imaging it's probably
the most common the most popular method
of brain imaging put very simply what
fMRI does is it measures the amount of
oxygen in the blood in different parts
of the brain in a very very precise way
and this is important because bits of
the brain that are more active where the
neurons the brain cells are firing a lot
they'll consume more energy and so the
blood in those parts of the brain will
have a bit less oxygen so we can tell
how active a certain part of the brain
is by looking at how the oxygenation
level to change and in fact it's still a
very active area of research to figure
out how that signal of oxygenation
actually relates to neurons firing
neuroscience says doing this one thing
makes you just as happy as eating mm
chocolate bars what is it a smile one of
our main sources of pleasure in the
world is social bonding so whenever we
feel that we're getting some recognition
of some affection or some positive
response from another human being
then we're gonna feel a lot better
whether it's exactly the same kind of
pleasure that we get from eating a
chocolate bar I don't know I don't
generally feel guilty if somebody smiles
at me in the same way that I do if I've
eaten a couple of chocolate bars on the
sly now I hope I've been able to answer
some of your questions but the great
thing about neuroscience is there's so
much more to discover this has been
neuroscience support with annual Seth